Hi, everyone.
How are you?
Can you hear me okay?
Awesome.
All right.
I'm really, really excited to be here today
with you all.
Look, yes, my name is Patima.
So, a quick introduction.
I'm the head of product and design at 7 west
media in Australia.
I'm from Perth.
And we have very adorable quokka animals.
That's me traveling here for the first time
ever in Europe.
And I'm super, super excited to be here.
It's amazing and it's quite an experience.
So, I bring over with me a little bit of Aussie
slang.
So, as I have been told that my accent is
quite strong, so I hope you can all understand
me.
But we do like to have a few idioms where
we can connect and concatenate words together.
And the words I want to run through you all
today is hard yakka.
Who has heard of the term before.
We have a few hands there.
Hey in the back there.
Now, hard yakka is the meaning of it is basically
hard work.
And it comes from rural slang, essentially.
So, in the country there's wood, which is
referred to as yakka.
And hard yakka is that meaning of hard work
and work ethic.
And this term reminds me of my granddad.
Look how cute he is.
He's adorable.
But he's one of the most hard working people
I know, and he's got an amazing work ethic.
And just one of those people that has sage
advice for any scenario.
And he's one of my greatest role models.
So, he'll say things like, work hard and be
good to your mother.
Listen before you speak.
And never say gonna, because if you're gonna,
you haven't done it yet.
And he's taught me a lot about work ethic
and having just, I suppose, that determination
to really apply myself and to work hard no
matter no matter what the circumstance and
just set goals and go for it.
So, he's really taught me a lot about resilience
and diligence.
And determination, of course.
But this transition of work ethic and hard
yakka in our industry has been something that
I have been trying to adjust to for this,
I don't know, 15 years I have been here working
in the web.
And the I suppose that concept of it is tricky
because, well, the state of our industry is
something that requires a lot of mental willpower.
And there's something that is not quite the
same about it like other industries would
have in a traditional sense.
So, I suppose I just wanted to ask you all
a few questions today, because this is something
that's been swirling around in my mind for
a little bit.
And it's the observation of, I suppose, what's
become normal in our industry.
Constant learning.
So, what I mean by this, as you know in our
industry, we're always learning something
new.
I suppose here's a simple question for you
all.
Who has learned something new this week?
Last week?
Last month?
Daily?
It's continuous and constant learning.
And it's also continuous change.
Another question for you all.
Who is doing the exact same workflow as what
they did two years ago?
One year ago?
One month ago?
Okay.
Sounds about right.
Also, community.
No, connectivity, I've jumped forward.
So, who hops on their laptops or their machines
after work?
Or on the weekends?
Oh, that's a lot of hands.
Yep.
Me too.
And who goes out and hangs out with the community?
Who runs or volunteers at or attends meetups
all the time?
Uh huh, uh huh.
Contributions.
Who is contributed to open source software
in this last week?
This month?
This year?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
And the last C that I wanted to bring in and
talk about is in the state of our industry
is also creativity.
And in that sense of, how many of you have
a side project going on or are working on
a side project, have worked on side projects,
thinking about working on a side project?
Yeah.
That's a that's a lot happening, right?
That's we're doing all of this stuff.
Probably on top of full time work or full
time study, and, you know, that's that's a
lot of hours that we're putting into this
world.
So, then I kind of got to thinking about,
you know, what is it that we value and normalize
as good, strong work ethic in our industry?
What's the hard yakka here?
And really, you know, it's it's what we value,
right?
As human beings and as professionals.
And you kind of hear these kind of praises
that swirl around and humble brags that happen.
These might sound familiar.
You know, there's Dev, it's super fast.
And then you might do the whole, I worked
nine hours today.
Well, I worked ten hours today.
I worked 24.
It's like this humble bragging that's happening.
And, you know, it's this kind of sense, oh,
well, that is what we consider maybe working
harder.
But then we've also got this kind of world
surrounding us as well which is, you know,
blog posts and contributing and working on
side projects and mentoring and all these
other things that we do to kind of keep progressing
our career forward.
And then we kind of have this really hard
wired mentality.
But, you know, we do all these things of,
well, so much to do and I'm so busy and these
are the general normal conversations that
we have.
And to me I kind of I kind of worry.
Because what we're saying to not only ourselves,
but to the people that are looking up to us
or that we speak to day to day, the things
that we're praising each other about are saying
these.
I suppose the translations, that somehow high
performance is shipping things quickly.
Regardless of quality, maintainability.
Yeah, smash it out.
Let's get other things done.
Or that clocking becomes this badge of pride
that's somehow related to productivity because
we're doing so much all the time and we're
always busy.
Is that a good thing?
And doing all of these things somehow is expected
of us to get ahead in this industry.
If you're not doing all of those things I
was listing out before with the state of our
industry somehow, you know, are we performing
the best that we can?
Are we meeting our potential?
And the other thing I'm reading into it is,
if we're always busy and needed, then this
relates to somehow the I'm valuable conversation.
So, I see a few nods out there.
And this is kind of my reaction to it.
Like, what is happening to our industry?
It doesn't quite sound right.
Kind of like this.
It's like a little yeah.
Oh, I love it.
So, suppose when we're kind of looking at
Googling.
Good old Google.
Leveling up, you know?
If we want to level up as developer or human
being, then all of a sudden, we have to go,
well, what are the steps that we need to take
to do that?
And all the things that are expected of us,
are they fair?
And I came across this Tweet from Eric Elliott
a little while ago and it really got me thinking.
It's one of those reflective pieces, right?
It's like, think of the most extraordinary
developer you have worked with and the traits
and qualities they have.
And the results of the survey, he wrote a
great blog post about it.
Feel free to go forth and check it out.
He came out with these top five qualities,
communicative, honest, top five traits, problem
solver, skilled, mentor, teacher, excellent
learner, passionate.
Cool.
Not bad.
These are things I would personally expect
any kind of working professional to have these
kinds of skills and traits.
But, you know, kind of add to this, we see
lots of mind maps around about the state of
the web.
And, wow, that just keeps going.
And that's from frontend to backend to DevOps
to, you know, sitting in this full stack world.
It's so full on and we're just learning all
these things constantly.
And all the expectations.
We should know everything.
And then we just it's tiring.
You know?
Do we do we accept this?
Do we accept that this is a healthy environment
that we want people to come into our industry
and go, hey, yeah?
Working ten hours to 15 hours to getting no
sleep and being busy all the time is cool.
Yeah.
I don't know.
With this save the world, I feel like it's
no wonder we're exhausted.
And it's no wonder we're seeing people talk
about, I suppose, the signs and symptoms of
burnout.
And I find that really concerning because
there's some really talented people that are
kind of hitting this stage and then not able
to recover.
And they're leaving the industry or changing
the industry or taking these massive breaks.
And when we're talking about it in a physical
sense, it's actually a thing called OTS.
Turn out, it's a symptom.
Overtraining syndrome is something that is
used to describe athletes who have completely
trained themselves to a state of, or overtrained
themselves to a state of mentor or physical
exhaustion.
And this is mega.
This is an imbalance of the simple equation
which is that training should be the result
of workout and recovery.
But when an athlete is diagnosed with OTS,
they're often out for 4 6 months.
Now, I've broke an few limbs in my time and
it only puts me out for 6 8 weeks.
So, this is massive.
And if we translate this into how this can
work with the mind, if we're burnt out from
just mental exhaustion of keeping up with
the industry and how the state of how things
are, then our energy is just going to be pretty
low.
And it's pretty hard to recover back from
zero.
, you know, when we get towards our energy
who plays Mortal Kombat or has?
That's the analogy.
When your power bar goes low.
And you're the at stage, you could lose this
game.
Boo.
But really, with that, is when you've got
full energy, you can actually you can do so
much more.
You can be creative and energetic.
And, you know, just be really inspired.
But when you're when you're low on energy,
you start to have, you know, have these uncharacteristic
things happen to yourself like you start forgetting
things.
You start having trouble with communication.
You know?
You start just being overwhelmed or it's just
it gets too much sometimes.
And this is something that I've experienced
at one point in my time over that 15 years.
There was a point where I was working so much
and not getting much sleep and what I decided
to do was make a change of reducing from full
time hours to three and a half days a week.
What that meant was that two people came on
board full time to replace that one and a
half days that I wasn't working.
I feel like that wasn't right.
Maybe.
So, zero.
It's a not a good thing when we're thinking
about energy.
So, how do we go about what are the ways that
we can move towards recharging this energy
bar?
Let's not maybe get to that zero point.
Let's see how we might be able to restock
our pantries and actually is pantries a word
that's used here?
Like a cupboard with food?
Yep.
Maybe?
Okay.
So, a pantry is like a cupboard that would
exist in your kitchen that you would actually
store things like canned fruits in and yep?
Okay.
So, look, when that's empty, and you're going
to reach in for more food and nothing's there
because you haven't been restocking it, well,
that's kind of the same thing with our energy
stores.
And ways that we can recharge are actually
pretty achievable.
They're all doable.
And I'll run you through a few of these methods.
Taking regular breaks.
Removing the noise.
Getting quality sleep.
Not working long hours.
And working on things that are meaningful
to you.
So, let's unpack these a bit further.
Because I think that they're really important
and there's some really, I suppose there's
some tools out there that we can use to really
help us along with this process.
So, taking regular breaks.
Yeah, sounds simple.
But it takes a lot of discipline.
It actually takes a lot of willpower to do
this.
And when you're super, super busy, or there's
a culture in your work place that taking breaks
is laziness or slacking off.
That's more of a struggle to do that.
Who does actually take regular breaks?
That's wonderful.
That's really great.
Because, you know, breaks breaks can actually
the science, of course.
There's a lot of studies which breaks can
replenish the psychological cost with working
hard, improving work performance and boosting
energy.
What they're actually helping do is your well,
the doggo your PXE, your pre frontal cortex.
The thinking part of your brain.
The part that takes on the logic and executive
functions, keeps you focused.
That's doing a lot.
That's the part that you're actually doing
to solve a lot of the problems in your day
to day.
And because it's doing so much, I feel like
doggo should get a break.
Let's recharge.
How can we take an effective break?
Schedule them at right times.
Know when you're really productive.
And I suppose one of the saying that is fairly
easy, but actually knowing when you're really
productive and what methods you might take
to go, okay, well, I'm going to go on a sprint
mode here and then take a rest here is actually
it's different and individual to how, you
know, we all work individually as well.
So, that is something to I know a lot of people
raised their hands but that's something that
is a little bit of tweaking required so that
we might recharge that chance of that overload
that we're feeling.
Taking an effective break is about leaving
your desk, leaving your workstation, giving
your eyes a rest.
Standing up and stretching, drinking water.
Actually, taking yourself out of that environment.
Leaving and then recharging and come back.
I can't begin to tell you how many times I've
walked away from my desk and was able to come
back after trying to figure out something
for ages and coming back and figuring out
it was a stinking semicolon or something ridiculous
like that.
It's all it took.
It took me a while to break out of these.
I had this hard yakka mentality.
And taking a break, maybe I'm slacking off.
Maybe I need to push through.
But that push through was really detrimental
to me.
So, the tools that I used for this was using
my calendar.
Actually, blanking out times of when I was
going to design in those breaks.
It was really important.
Because then I was taking control of that
calendar and taking control of that space.
Something like Slackbot reminders.
Who uses Slack here in their work?
Cool.
About 50%.
Setting up a Slack bot or whatever tool you
might be using internally to have little notifications
to remind yourself to stand up and stretch
every now and then is really, really excellent.
I had this designed in for my team I was working
with and doing that twice a day.
We use that as an activity to get away from
our desks and muster in the middle and take
a stretch break.
That's only five minutes twice a day.
It just meant we're able to have that break.
Who has heard of tiny care bot on Twitter?
It's adorable.
If you are on Twitter, hop along and follow
it along.
It's simple little gems that really just give
you a little boost.
So, let's move on to the next part of topping
up your energy bar.
Removing noise.
Now, when we think of working or in agile
development in any sense, we want to remove
all that noise and have this really, you know,
clear focus on what we're working on so that
we're not distracted by everything else that's
going along and not thinking about the backlog.
We basically are ensuring that what we're
working on is the important thing that we're
working on and supposed to be focused on right
there and then.
And we can give it our 100%.
So, what we want to do is remove the noise
so that we're not doing a situation where
when everything is important, nothing is important
scenario and trying to multi task and splitting
our focus across a few things.
So, how we want to reduce unwanted noise.
Same kind of agile methodologies.
Having calendar hygiene.
And checking in on that regularly.
And the calendar is something that is it's
such a strong tool that you can use in your
day to day.
By taking control of it, you can blank out
these areas in your day that you might be
able to go, well, I can focus for an hour
block here on this particular task.
Or I can blank out this whole day to just
play or learn or whatever that might be.
And it means that you can kind of continuously
look at it and take out things that might
not be relevant anymore.
Maybe you don't need to go to six meetups
this week.
Maybe you could just choose one that you really
want to focus on.
Writing things down and getting them out of
your head.
It's I highly recommend it.
Because when it's all swirling around up here,
it's just noise.
So, writing down the things that you want
to achieve and what you want to do.
And then going through and grooming those
goals.
Definitely, definitely a winner.
It's something that really helps with that
focus piece.
Do not disturb modes are another massive one
if you're going to go into a sprint.
A sprint being so, you know, if you wanted
to do a 20 minute session of just focus.
And then taking away those notifications as
well during those times.
Or notifications when you're out of hours
and after work which probably don't need to
be pinged at all in these times.
And most importantly, probably saying no is
a tricky one to do.
But that is all about taking control of our
lives and taking control of what we're spending
on what we do day to day.
Because there's a temptation to take on a
lot all the time.
But it's unnecessary.
So, I suggest I've suggested calendar a few
times and taking control of that.
Head space app is a really good app for meditation
and taking bringing mindfulness into the approach
and that is something that you can essentially
use to reduce the noise that's going along
going on in there.
But it's, you know, it's a great tool if that's
where you would like to head to.
There's also a Slack bot called stop, breathe
and think which is pretty good as well.
It brings up reminders for you.
And has anyone used the momentum plugin?
Kind of looks like this.
Yeah, got a couple of hands there.
It's a great little Chrome and Firefox plugin
that you can install, and it just gives you
a focus mode.
So, you can just focus on one task at a time.
And then you have your other little goals
that you have set up at least on the side.
And, yeah.
It just gives you that chance to just go,
okay, I'm going to hone in on one thing and
one thing only.
How great?
And that was the Slack bot that I was talking
about.
Okay.
On to a third way of recharging your energy
bar.
Getting sleep.
What does our life look like about healthy
sleep?
Lack of concentration, tiredness, inability
to make decisions, memory loss, lower tolerance.
It's not great.
And I did actually go through a time where
I was getting about four hours of sleep a
night for about three years running.
Oh.
I was able to persevere.
And that hard yakka mentality really pushed
me through it.
But it really it really got me to a point
where I was not starting to like what I was
doing anymore.
It was possibly just a bit much.
I just did not think that I could sustain
this.
And when we're thinking about OTS, I was getting
pretty tired.
And I came across this quote.
I thought it was pretty apt.
If you routinely lose sleep or choose to sleep
less than needed, it adds up.
It's called your sleep dep.
You have a sleep dep of 14 hours after a week.
And turns out it's not something that can
be paid off via naps either, sleep debt.
It's a fundamental of actually being able
to have a good night's sleep and be rested
enough to be able to tackle the following
day.
There are so many resources out there about
going, okay, how do we get a good night's
sleep and be rested and well recovered and
energized up?
And look, just a few things that can get you
started along the way if you're having trouble
sleeping at all.
Avoid looking at a device an hour before bedtime,
consistent routine, avoid alcohol and caffeine
six to seven hours before bed, that can be
hard.
And exercising.
These are simple steps that you can take towards
that.
And it's that first step that is the one that
really takes you towards putting and prioritizing
your wellness first there.
So, quickly just run you through.
Yep, try these tools.
Yeah, having the reoccurring reminder, the
sleep cycle apps, and the sleep bot app that
monitors your sleep patterns and wakes you
up in a window that's not within your REM.
And I've got two more things to go through.
Don't work on hours.
Easy to say.
Little trickier to do.
But super important.
There's this term that happens, I suppose,
in our industry.
And actually, a lot of industries called presentism.
This is the practice of being present in one's
place of work for more hours that is required,
especially as a manifestation of insecurity
about one's job.
It's not it's not great.
It's not great.
And when we have the culture, remember, I
was saying when, you know, you're hearing
the praise about, oh, well, I worked 10 hours
and 20 hours hey, good on you.
great.
But did they actually get much done during
that time?
Was that really productive?
And were they able to recover from that?
So, let's kind of play at the scenario of
what it would look like if we were to happen
to leave on time.
Well, you would leave work on time.
Look, make, who knows, improvement on time
management and communication.
Because if you are leaving at the time you
are supposed to be leaving, perhaps people
might be more prepared to catch you before
you go.
Maybe they might be more organized to say,
okay, well, I really need you for X, Y, Z.
Can we catch up in the window where you're
available?
And you might then become a better communicator
of saying I'm not available from this time
onwards.
Maybe catch me in a window I'm available.
Again, taking control of that calendar again.
And, I mean, it sounds pretty awful, but you
get time to do the things that you really
like to enjoy.
Or enjoy doing or that are important to you.
Wouldn't that be a bit ace?
So, here's the methods I would suggest just
getting started with that.
Because it can be difficult, especially if
there's a culture in your work place where
people are staying back or online all the
time because that's the state of our industry,
right?
Maybe just start by booking in a few after
work appointments.
Whether that's a coffee and a cake with someone.
Whether that's a walking catchup with someone
else.
But having a regular routine, maybe something
like a fitness group or rock climbing or whatever
activity to take on that you're doing with
someone else means you have that responsibility.
You can go out and do it together with your
buddy.
And committing to leaving on time is really
something that is going to take a lot of discipline.
And working in that habit might be a little
tricky at first, but then you start to be
okay with it.
And here's a really important one if you are
working a lot of open source projects.
Ask your boss and create that culture within
that environment that you're working in for
these contributions to be happening during
work hours.
I think this is professional development.
I think this is the way as an employee or
someone working in the industry you're growing
your skills in that way.
And that training should be endorsed and encouraged
within work hours in some way, share, or form.
So, you know, that and also if you're going
to a lot of meetups, that's also training
as well.
Maybe balance that out, okay, if I'm going
to meetup one night can I come in later the
next day?
That was learning time.
Taking control of that more so you can spend
time on things that matter.
And the hard yakka side of it really comes
into knowing and understanding that your time
is precious.
And really that's our most valuable commodity.
So, shouldn't we be dedicating that to things
that bring us joy?
Or making us more us?
What about spending time with family and friends?
What about prioritizing your interests and
hobbies?
Learning and discovery, playing, travel, exploration.
We're all very unique human beings that are
inspired by different things.
So, why not embrace that?
And something that might help towards that
so that you might have some more energy to
contribute to it is a journal.
Getting things out of your head and reflecting
on it means you might have that chance to
see it laid out rather than just swirling
around in your mind.
Feel free to get a Pinterest or a happiness
board up and running.
Those visuals give you those reminders constantly.
And deliberately booking time for play.
Again, taking ownership of your calendar.
So, I say, in your own way, and that energized
people can do even more, and we should take
care of ourselves and take care of each other.
And what my grandad would say is, hard yakka
is good, but don't be a dingo.
Thank you.